après l'ouverture des frontières aux
migrants décidée par la turquie l'union
européenne voit le spectre de la crise
migratoire de 2015 ressurgir alors
quelles réponses face à ce chantage
d'ankara quelle stratégie commune
quel sera le rôle de la turquie c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec pierre berthelot chercheur
associé à l'institut prospective et
sécurité en europe directeur également
de la revue orient stratégique bonsoir
bientôt
merci d'être avec nous en direct par
skype de nice and had made avocate
spécialisée notamment dans le droit des
migrants bonsoir madame mad merci d'être
avec nous en direct donc depuis ni
saveur tout d'abord on va s'arrêter un
petit peu sur l'aspect politique on a vu
cette réunion entre vladimir poutine et
recep tayyib erdogan qui a donné un
accord sur un cessez le feu tout d'abord
pierre berthelot est ce qu'on peut il
croire à ce cessez le feu
on peut y croire
la question c'est est ce qu'il va être
durable oui c'est ça c'est la question
voilà oui là on y croit les médias en
tout cas oui c'est long terme sont bien
de temps il va durer donc inquiet voilà
je pense qu'il peut être mise en oeuvre
mais pour combien de temps et c'est vrai
que ça va être en partie liée à la
réponse qui sera apportée par l'europe à
la crise migratoire donc on voit qu'on a
un jeu avec trois acteurs si on peut
dire à la russie la turquie et l'union
européenne
et donc on verra quelle réponse va
apporter l'union européenne annan mad
vous avez porté beaucoup d'espoir
concernant cette situation on parlera
évidemment de des migrants plus tard
mais voilà cette rencontre cet après
midi elle est porteuse d'espoir pour
vous bien évidemment elle est porteuse
d'espoir si les deux états tiennent
leurs promesses c'est à dire que c'est
ce soit dans un long terme et peut
effectivement les populations puissent
se considérer en sécurité parce que si
tel n'est pas le cas on va dans une
situation catastrophique puisque
actuellement la crise politique entre
l'europe et erdogan
eto'o est au plus haut alors pierre
berthelot vous nous disiez ça va
dépendre un petit peu de latitude de
l'europe alors on va s'y arrêter
plusieurs minutes sur cette europe que
peut-elle faire que doit-elle faire tout
d'abord face à ce chantage d'ardoyne
certains invités hier me disais on va en
écouter un plus tard mais voilà que tout
simplement il faudrait même pas avoir à
répondre à ce président turquie viol
le territoire tout simplement européen
c'est une atteinte à la souveraineté de
l'europe qu'est ce que vous répondez à
savoir on peut sans se faire l'avocat de
la turquie rappelé aussi le contexte que
donc il ya eu une crise migratoire qui
dure depuis plusieurs années en partie à
cause des conflits dans la région et
qu'il y avait un accord qui avait été
passé en 2016 entre l'union européenne
et la turquie pour l'aider à gérer ce
flux
donc finalement l algérie la masse des
migrants c'est la turquie qui les a
quand même accueilli il faut le rappeler
c'est vrai qu'en 2015 l'europe en a
accueilli un peu plus d'un million y en
a plusieurs millions en turquie donc
elle porte un poids énorme
elle fait une partie du travail c'est à
dire en les retenant chez elle mais en
contrepartie elle avait on lui avait
promis plusieurs milliards voilà et du
point de vue turc
cet accord n'aurait pas été totalement
respecté c'est à dire les sommes qui ont
été promises n'ont pas été totalement
alloués à la turquie donc du point de
vue turc l'a saisi cette opportunité
d'une nouvelle crise humanitaire
suite effectivement à l'offensive qu'on
a eu autour de la région d'idlib pour
dire cette fois ci à l'europe
ben voilà il faut respecter l'accord
qu'on avait passé qui avait été que
partiellement
du point de vue turc encore une fois
respecté donc effectivement on peut
trouver ça scandaleux
cette position tueur voilà qui ferait
une espèce de chantage mais du point de
vue turc il s'agit pas d'un chantage
il s'agit finalement de rappeler à
l'europe les engagements que du point de
vue encore une fois turque elle n'aurait
pas tenu
madame havana nomade vous partager la
vie de pierre berthelot on doit quand
même parlé à la turquie qui
effectivement fait un chantage même si
elles elles sont défend on doit répondre
à un chantage les européens bien
évidemment il faut rappeler que la
turquie actuellement à environ 3,6
millions de réfugiés essentiellement
syrien donc on doit discuter aujourd'hui
avec lattes avec la turquie et trouver
un accord parce que si tel n'est pas le
cas
là effectivement erdogan va continuer à
laisser passer les réfugiés sur le sol
européen parce que comme il le dit
lui-même
l'europe doit prendre sa part du fardeau
donc il n'ya pas de raison pour erdogan
à ce que la turquie fasse seul face à ce
tout simplement à ce mouvement des
réfugiés syriens qui bat tout simplement
vont vouloir chercher à se protéger et à
l'est vers l'europe pour demander
l'asile
donc aujourd'hui le rempart le plus
important c'est la turquie puisque la
turquie accueille une grande majorité
donc de ces réfugiés syriens
tout simplement parce qu'elle est à
proximité mais si la turquie demain ne
venez pas à continuer à respecter cet
accord
erdogan le sait ça va poser une crise
une nouvelle crise migratoire en europe
une crise migratoire je pense d'une
ampleur plus importante que celle de
et ça l'europe ne peut pas se le
permettre actuellement
donc on doit continuer de discuter avec
la turquie et trouver un nouvel accord
puisque l'accord de 2016
vraisemblablement ne peut plus tenir
est ce que souhaite en réalité un dos
d'âne c'est avoir davantage d'argent
avoir davantage de moyens et je pense ce
qu'ils souhaitent
hoog avantage c'est obtenir l'argent
directement auprès des autorités turques
et non pas auprès d'associations et ong
pierre berthelot oui et oui il ya une
contradiction encore une fois dans la
position européenne deuxième
contradiction c'est finalement on sait
que ces vagues migratoires viennent en
partie des conflits du proche orient
voilà dont la syrie et dans le même
temps l'europe n'a pas vraiment une
position claire pour tenter de régler le
problème en syrie
ça l'amènerait à dialoguer avec la
russie elle y est plutôt hostile
donc ça c'est compliqué cela ne devrait
être utile en ce moment oui m
oui ils ont même qu'on aime pas vladimir
on était là on entendait un journal
allemand la 9e pas forcément venus
régime qui salué comme le beau succès on
est pris à la non mais pour des raisons
idéologiques on se refuse à parler avec
la russie qui est quand même un acteur
majeur dans la région on se refuse aussi
à parler ou en tout cas à établir un
vrai dialogue avec la turquie
voilà donc c'est compliqué à partir du
moment où on finalement l'origine du
problème c'est les gars du proche orient
dans lesquels finalement il faut le
rappeler
les occidentaux ont une lourde
responsabilité parce que quand on a
déclenché la guerre par exemple en irak
en 2003 c'était les américains mais avec
plusieurs pays européens qui l'ont
soutenu où ils sont ces pays européens
aujourd'hui pour agir pour tenter de
régler les conflits dans lesquels ils
ont une part de responsabilité
on aimerait savoir dont klaus ne faisait
pas partie services r tout à fait c'est
pour ça qu'elle a probablement un rôle à
jouer et on aimerait davantage entendre
emmanuel macron dans le cadre du
rapprochement qui l'avait opéré avec des
meilleures poutines à l'été dernier on
aimerait peut-être voir des je pense
qu'il ya une opportunité assez
exceptionnel pour la france justement
parce que elle a une longue tradition
finalement de connaissance de la série
puisqu'elle y étaient présentes il ya un
certain temps voilà elle a des liens
avec le liban donc je pense que la
france pourrait jouer un rôle mais
encore une fois on voit qu'à chaque fois
qu'il manuel mal qu'on veut se
rapprocher de la russie il ya l'union
européenne qui est derrière et qui lui
dit non mais surtout pas voilà au
contraire il faut regarder ce rapport de
force donc à une contradiction delà de
l'union européenne qui tant qu'elle ne
sera pas résolue
je pense qu'on avancera voit beaucoup il
ya surtout peut-être une contradiction
qui se soldent tout simplement par une
impuissance je sais pas si vous allez
être d'accord tous les deux avec les
eurodéputés rn là qu'ils qualifiaient
d'impuissance l'union européenne
d'europe molle est ce qu'on peut la
qualifier ainsi
madame hamad dans ce dossier or vous
vous partagez cet avis des eurodéputés
du rassemblement national
alors la difficulté pour l'europe c'est
que depuis 2015
elle est dans l'incapacité de trouver
une réponse unique une réponse tout
simplement des 27 dirigeants sur la
question de l'immigration
donc aujourd'hui gagne évidemment on
voit que tous les pays s'accordent à
soutenir la grèce compte elle re foule
ces migrants qui arrivent mais on ne
parle pas de la question fondamentale
qu'allons nous faire de ces migrants
s'il arrive sur le sol européen et
surtout personne ne condamne ce qui se
passe effectivement sur zone de mer à
savoir notamment la vidéo qui a tourné
sur plusieurs sites internet des
gardes-cotes donc grecque qui tire sur
sur des migrants
donc l'europe aujourd'hui est incapable
est ce qu'elle est molle oui
effectivement elle est mal puisqu'elle
est incapable de trouver une solution
commune et une réponse commune à ces
explications de migration maintenant
bien évidemment que les extrêmes droites
vont utiliser cette actualité pour
pouvoir augmenter leur leurs votants
je pense que si l'europe aujourd'hui ne
trouve pas de solution adaptée des
solutions communes et dont elle va faire
le jeu tout simplement d extrême droite
dans toute l'union européenne
alors vous posez
la question et vous ouvrait la voie à
s'interroger sur le profil des migrants
je voudrais vous faire écouter un son
olivier delorme et historien auteur de
la greffe et les belles quand il était
sur notre plateau hier pour lui on
s'interroge quand même sur le profil de
ces migrants car selon lui personne
n'est capable de savoir parmi eux
combien serez susceptible de commettre
un attentat écouter ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à la frontière ça se passe
aux cris de allahou akbar et c'est à
dire que les gentils migrants qui
soi-disant viennent chercher une vie
meilleure en europe
en réalité il ya là dedans beaucoup de
beaucoup de combattants que monsieur
erdogan amène de syrie comme il en a
mais n'en comme il en a mais n'en lire
et en libye et qu'on est incapable
aujourd'hui de ceux de savoir parmi ces
migrants combien il y en a qui demain
commettront des attentats en europe
occidentale s'il passe là s'ils passent
cette frontière
alors pierre berthelot c'est sûr que ça
c'est un discours qu'on n'a pas vraiment
l'habitude d'entendre en ce moment sur
les médias occidentaux c'est pour ça que
voulez vous faire écouter ce sont ça
vous choque
est ce qu'il ya un peu de vrai ça pose
la question du profil de ces migrants il
faut pas minimiser ou parce qu'on l'a
fait dans le passé
malheureusement plusieurs médias la
possibilité qui est parmi ces migrants
des membres de groupes radicaux et c'est
ce qu'on avait nié que ça pouvait être
le cas on sait que parmi les gens qui
avaient comme il est attendu bataclan
notamment il y en avait bon après dans
dans la masse de tous ces migrants
on peut quand même considérer que l'ama
l'immense majorité c'est quand même des
gens qui fuient une situation
humanitaire catastrophique économiques
politiques etc
mais on peut pas négliger ce risque
après est ce que c'est le risque
principal c'est vrai qu'après tout c'est
difficile à évaluer
parce qu'on ne sait pas véritablement
qui comptabilise ces migrants quel
comment ça se passe quand il arrive
voilà donc il ya une problématique mais
je pense pas que erdogan soit assez fou
si amant pour lâcher si je puis dire
dans la nature
et des djihadistes si je peux je pas
convaincu en tout cas se sont enfuis
voilà alors après voilà peut-être qu'il
y en a qui passent à travers mais de là
à dire que la turquie le ferait de façon
consciente et je suis pas tout à fait
certain and may de laon vainqueur au
coeur du sujet que vous connaissez bien
ça vous chante ses propos d'olivier
delorme son voisin derrière on disait
également il n'y a pas que des réfugiés
politiques loin le doigt parmi ces
migrants la roseraie convoi d voilà des
images sur les chaînes françaises qui
peuvent
voilà peut-être parfois faire penser
l'inversé quel est votre avis vous est
ce que c'est un discours choquant pour
vous alors je dirais pas que c'est un
disque ou choquants je dirais que c'est
un discours auquel on s'attend venant
d'une personne qui certainement et
d'extrême droite
c'est à dire que c'est un discours où on
veut faire peur dans clairement on veut
faire peur maintenant ce discours il y a
lieu d'être puisque bien évidemment il
ya eu des attentats donc on doit se
poser la question
on ne doit pas tout simplement tenté de
dire il n'y aura pas deux
de de radicaliser dans ou des
terroristes dans les migrants qui vont
arriver certainement qu'il y en a mais
le problème c'est qu'en réalité on n'en
sait rien on n'en sait rien puisqu'on
est dans l'incapacité de gérer
aujourd'hui ce flux migratoire de
contrôler les personnes qui vont passer
la frontière
donc on ne peut pas dire que le risque
est un risque zéro
mais maintenant venir refoulé toutes les
personnes qui sont des réfugiés dans la
grande majorité ne sont pas des
terroristes
je pense que ce serait pas la bonne
solution la bonne solution c'est de
faire en sorte aujourd'hui de pouvoir
maîtriser ce flux de pouvoir maîtriser
ce flux pour rassurer les européens sur
le risque qui est réel qui peut exister
que parmi ces personnes qui arrivent il
y ait des terroristes parce que ça dira
le contraire dire qu'aujourd'hui on peut
rassurer et dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
terroristes c'est faux mais dire le
contraire c'est également faux parce
qu'en réalité on n'en sait rien donc je
pense que il est urgent
vu la situation actuelle de pouvoir
maîtriser ce flux de pouvoir maîtriser
les personnes qui arrivent et c'est là
effectivement on va poser une question
qui est importante celle d'une d'une
politique migratoire commune en europe
et de pouvoir prendre en charge les
personnes réfugiés syriens ou autre on
charge mais de manière où on peut les
identifier et de manière on peut avoir
une certaine traçabilité pour rassurer
d'une part les européens mais surtout
pour faire preuve tout simplement de
d'humanité de prise en charge face à ces
crises politiques migratoires qui sont
importantes mais il faut rappeler qu'à
l'origine de tout ça il y à des guerres
il y a des enfants il ya des femmes il
ya des hommes qui ont souffert et donc
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui continue à
faire comme si il n'existait pas
parce qu'en réalité ce que vient de
faire un robot gagnent c'est de montrer
aux européens le nombre important de
réfugiés syriens qui existe et
auxquelles on n'avait plus fait face
depuis 2000 15 depuis 2016 en réalité
depuis qu'on a trouvé
l'accord avec la turquie pierre
berthelot annan hahnemann nous dit il
faut trouver une solution enfin ça fait
depuis 2015 qu'on la cherche c'est qu'on
la trouve pas comment pourquoi est-ce
aussi compliqué de trouver une stratégie
commune pour notamment la le droit
d'asile la répartition des migrants sur
le territoire européen
encore une fois ça tient
à la diversité de l'union européenne
c'est à dire qu'avec à 27 ou à 28
c'est forcément plus difficile cassis ou
k12 donc ça c'est en l'éternelle
question de l'élargissement qui a été
trop rapide etc
je pense que il n'y a pas grand chose à
attendre de ces négociations
l'union européenne qui sont
interminables je pense qu'il faut qu'un
groupe de pays leaders prennent des
décisions prennent l'initiative la
france l'italie l'allemagne voilà
et qu'ils essayent de poser un certain
nombre de règles et qui met en place un
dispositif
je ne crois pas qu'on pourra parvenir à
une position unanime de 27 pays
je suis assez sceptique et c'est une des
causes finalement de ceux de cet échec
parce que on tergiverse sans arrêt on
n'arrive pas à avoir une position
commune en a aussi un conflit de valeurs
finalement quelles sont les valeurs de
l'union européenne et depuis certaines
un certain nombre d'années on voit que
s'opposent
finalement des pays conservateurs très
hostile à toute politique migratoire et
de l'autre des pays qui sont plus
ouverts par tradition philosophique ou
politique et se posera aussi la question
du moyen de les accueillir
effectivement qui sont extrêmement
compliqué ça sera certainement l'objet
d'un autre débat merci à tous les deux
annan made en direct de nice pierre
bartolo sur ce plateau merci d'avoir
accepté le débat et on se retrouve dans